TOMORROW NIGHT IN NEW YORK.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT HAS DECIDED THAT
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS DURING
ITS FINAL WEEKS IN OFFICE SHOULD
FUND A WALL ALONG OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH MEXICO.
THAT'S NOT A NEW IDEA,
OBVIOUSLY.
TRUMP RAN FOR OFFICE BEGINNING
THREE YEARS AGO ON THAT VERY
PROMISE.
VOTERS AGREED WITH THAT, THEY
ELECTED HIM.
NOW HE'S DEMANDING UNEQUIVOCALLY
THAT THE WALL FINALLY GET BUILT.
AT THE SAME TIME, AND THIS IS
NOT A COINCIDENCE, THE NEWS
MEDIA HAS IDENTIFIED THE SINGLE
MOST RACIST IDEA THAN ANYONE IN
THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY HAS
EVER COME UP WITH, THAT IS OF
COURSE BUILDING A WALL ALONG OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH MEXICO.
WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT TO THE
HEART OF WHAT I CALL HIS BROWN
MENACE THEORY.
THESE MIGRANTS, THEY ARE DIRTY
PEOPLE.
THEY BRING DISEASE.
>> THIS BORDER WALL THING IS
ABOUT CONTROLLING THE BROWNING
OF AMERICA.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS FIXATED ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AS HE WAS
THE DAY HE ANNOUNCED HIS
CAMPAIGN.
IT IS NOT ABOUT SECURING THE
BORDER, IT IS ABOUT XENOPHOBIC,
RACIST, BIGOTED LEAFS.
>> Tucker: THAT COULDN'T BE
CLEARER.
BORDER WALLS ARE RACIST.
WE KNOW THAT.
UNLIKE BORDER FENCES.
BORDER FENCES ARE NOT RACIST.
THEY ARE MUCH EASIER TO CLIMB
OVER AND THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS
HAVE REPEATEDLY VOTED TO FUND
THEM.
IF YOU COULD HAVE LOTS OF BORDER
FENCES AND STILL WIND UP WITH
22 MILLION ILLEGAL ALIENS LIVING
IN THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE PROVED THAT CONCLUSIVELY
OVER THE YEARS.
FENCES ARE THE PERFECT SOLUTION
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO PRETEND THAT
YOU CARE ABOUT BORDER SECURITY
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY ENCOURAGING
MUCH OF THE THIRD WORLD TO MOVE
HERE WITHOUT PERMISSION.
FENCES ARE AWESOME FOR THAT.
BUT WALLS, AS NANCY PELOSI HAS
EXPLAINED, WALLS ARE IMMORAL.
ACCORDING TO CNN, WALLS ARE
NOTHING LESS THEN AN ATTACK ON
THE HUMAN HEART.
LISTEN AND LEARN.
>> AND A WALL WON'T SOLVE IT.
ALL HE'S DOING IS PUTTING UP
WALLS AROUND PEOPLE'S HEARTS.
>> WE ARE NOT A WALL AWAY FROM
BEING BETTER.
>> DON'T WASTE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY IN
ORDER TO BUILD SOMETHING THAT
WILL NOT MAKE OUR BORDER MORE
SECURE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE OTHER
POINT THEY KEEP MAKING.
WALLS DON'T WORK.
THEY ARE TOTALLY INEFFECTIVE
EXCEPT IN PRISONS AND THE
VATICAN AND OUTSIDE
BARACK OBAMA'S HOUSE HERE IN
WASHINGTON AND ALMOST EVERY
UPPER INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD IN
AMERICA WHERE WALLS SURROUND THE
FRONT LINES OF THE HOMES
HILLARY CLINTON AND BETO
O'ROURKE HOLD THEIR
FUND-RAISERS.
BUT AMONG INTERNATIONAL BORDERS,
WALLS ARE USELESS.
A PORTABLE WOULD SIMPLY CREATE A
THRIVING NEW MARKET IN TALLER
LETTERS.
JEB BUSH USED TO SAY THAT ALL
THE TIME.
EVERYONE IN POWER AGREES WITH
HIM.
THEY ARE NOT OR NODDING
VIGOROUSLY FROM THEIR GATED
COMMUNITIES.
>> WE NEED BORDER SECURITY, THE
WALL AS A PART OF BORDER
SECURITY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE VERY GOOD
SECURITY WITHOUT A WALL.
>> THAT IS A POLITICAL PROMISE.
BORDER SECURITY IS A WAY TO
EFFECTIVELY HONOR OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> THE EXPERTS SAY YOU CAN DO
BORDER SECURITY WITHOUT A WALL,
WHICH IS WASTEFUL AND DOESN'T
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: IT'S WASTEFUL.